d'accord, écoutez, c'est ainsi que nous accordons la
priorité à la santé et à la sécurité
en veillant à ce qu'il y ait un
mandat de vaccination qui atteigne tout le monde
universellement dans le secteur privé beaucoup
de gens du secteur privé m'ont dit
qu'ils croient en la vaccination
mais ils ne sont pas tout à fait sûrs  comment ils peuvent le
faire eux-mêmes bien nous allons le faire
tout le monde dans la ville
et aussi au travail, vous savez que cela ne
vous protège pas seulement en tant qu'individu, cela
aide également à protéger vos amis, les
membres de votre famille, vos collègues en
même temps, vous devriez obliger les gens à faire
quelque chose qu'ils ne veulent pas faire.  ce n'est pas
c'est grossier ou inhabituel ce n'est pas les droits de l'homme que
vous devez protéger la plupart des
gens
et cela a été prouvé par les scientifiques
jusqu'à présent sur la recherche que je comprends
que
cela nous protège le plus si tout le monde
a le vaccin donc
je soutiens  c'est
vous